it's just coagulated pig blood this
right it's the lining of a beef stomach
yeah this looks spicy I'm shaking oh oh
oh my god what's up it's just wine I'm
spices oh my god oh it makes me sneeze
oh my god is it we're the taste like
Italian food to me they're like pizza
there's nothing taste like pizza I can't
taste anything except fire oh look at
that line of pork belly is one of the
best cuts of meat in existence and it
somehow ruined the pork belly was like
not tender it's very dry that's really
good
oh man these are good flavors have some
pineapple slices in here yeah you can do
better than this schedule on this is my
regular order at Chinese restaurant but
this is the real kung pao chicken right
what's the difference between this
chicken and let's see an American
compound Oh so into this big it's kind
of flus really deceptive so it like
starts off really tasty and then it got
mean like every single boyfriend I've
ever had I this is an inflammatory
trigger powerful the pleasurable that
irreplaceable Kung Pao
[Music]
so hashbrowns it also just kind of looks
like a worm please be like spaghetti
this is a palate cleanser because all
that food is so spicy I'm kind of into
it matter french fries that you dropped
in water this would be a great side dish
we could fry them and make them much
better this is what as a kid I hope the
worms would taste like what I'm gonna
tap out of that on the juke card there's
no way I'm using pig's blood sometime
you want to impress people I'd go on
fear factor that's delicate it liquefied
as soon as I took a bite oh I think my
palate has certainly evolved today it's
one of those foods that I say you might
have the the next morning but though to
be worth it I love the spice
way to go Szechuan I mean it's blood
fight of it it just will you said we're
eating blood